like most other programming languages
JavaScript gives us evaluators to
compare us prescience we can see if data
are less than greater than equal to or
some combination of those three for this
lesson we'll be sticking with equality
and equal to uses three equal signs not
two sort of it can use either three
equal signs or two but the three equal
sign version is slightly safer there's a
link in the instructors notes explaining
the difference let's run through a
simple if statement to check out the
syntax and give evaluation a try like if
some condition is true then do something
there's an if statement within the
parentheses and then if it evaluates to
true we perform whatever action comes
between the curly braces if the
condition isn't equal to true we can use
an else statement to do something else
in that case we simply use the keyword
else at another curly brace and then an
alternate set of commands that performs
if this original condition
isn't true this syntax for if statements
follows the same patterns as if
statements in Python but notice that we
have to include our conditions in
parentheses here and that the statements
that perform if this condition is true
come between curly braces also note
there's no colon after the condition in
JavaScript here's an example if tired
equals true drink coffee else drink
water if I'm tired
I'll go get some coffee otherwise I'll
drink water so how do you think we'll
use if statements to build the resume
looking at our header we've got these
skills which we may or may not want to
include if we do decide to include this
list well first need to create it and
we'll need to create this skills at a
glance heading so how can we see if we
need to create the list I think we
should use an if statement you know what
this is gonna make a good quiz yeah I
think so to write an if statement that
checks whether or not there are any
skills in the biography object write an
if statement that checks
not there any skills in the bio object
if there are skills the if-statement
should evaluate to true and then append
HTML skills start to the div with ID
header
once that's done append each skill to
the element with ID equals skills by
formatting them with HTML skills you
could find HTML skills in helper j/s if
you're interested what it looks like
when you've finished up and you can see
the skills on the page check this box